if you wanted to design what are the the
worst possible things you could expose
yourself to when trying to get inflow or
do something
meaningful and deep probably email and
social media would be what you would
come up with like if you were a mad
scientist saying like my
my goal is not to take over the world
but to reduce productivity as much as
possible those would be what you would
design
do you purposefully go out of your way
to write the most shocking and
triggering books in the world
you know otherwise i get bored so if
you're if you're going to spend a couple
of years working on a book and getting
it out there my philosophy is you might
as well take a big swing
because i don't know i couldn't imagine
anything more tedious than just
i call it writing for the sake of
writing but just coming up with an idea
that
this qualifies as a reasonable thing to
write a book about and
crafting the book and putting out there
no one cares i like to take big swings
so i either want to hit the ball out of
the park or twist around and fall down
after i miss but that's more interesting
i think than
uh playing it safe yeah i totally agree
it seems to me looking at kind of the uh
cal newport verse at the moment that the
deep work philosophy is kind of the
central thrust and then
currently you're creating different
delivery mechanisms and doing
objection handling for what's getting in
the way of achieving it
do you reckon that's a fair assessment i
think that
that explains deep work in a world
without email if we want to
increase the umbrella big enough to also
capture digital minimalism
the the term that was born basically of
the pandemic so over the last year
the the term i coined was the deep life
and i see if the deep life is sort of
the umbrella concept that most of this
work goes under so it includes work and
includes
the world outside of works in the world
of work the deep life pushes towards
deep work so the book deep work is about
that the book of world without email is
about
the the structural and organizational
obstacles
to having this more fulfilling work and
then probably digital minimalism which
is more about your phone and social
media in your personal life that's more
about
making your life deeper outside
of work so i'm trying to unify
everything i talk about with this
with this word deep
yeah and what's the end goal of that uh
i want a deeper life it's what
i just think it's important i mean look
i'm i'm interested in my life being as
deep as possible and i have to write
about what i care about
there's also just a huge hunger for it
and i didn't really articulate this is
what i was doing
until i began podcasting during the
pandemic and
having a much tighter feedback loop with
my audience and realizing that there's
this real hunger out there i think
there's a lot of people
in the us for sure but in a lot of other
countries as well
young people newly emerging middle-aged
people like in my cohort that
are relatively i would say adrift and
what i mean by adrift is that they're
not actually
rooted to resilient philosophies
or foundational systems right so that's
sort of just going through careerism in
life and something comes and
knocks you off your path and you don't
know what to do or nothing knocks you
off your path but work just seems what
am i doing here i'm just on email all
day
there's a hunger for this and we see
that hunger out there
and that's a it's a hunger i feel and
i'm trying to feed
all of the previous wisdom that our
parents generation and even the stuff
that i did
at a business bachelors and then uh
marketing masters 13 years ago
or 12 years ago most of that feels
irrelevant now
this is how quick the world is moving
there was no
social media marketing when i did it it
was just after you needed to have a
university email address to get on
facebook twitter wasn't there instagram
wasn't there
there was no such thing as influencer
marketing there was no talk about
productivity systems on how to
get past the digital minions and the
the pitfalls that you can tumble down so
it doesn't surprise me that this is an
emerging
field right the technology is always
going to move quicker than the cultural
artifacts
that teach us how to keep up with it and
even quicker than the legislation which
might actually be needed to help control
people's use
yeah everything moves quickly and
everything has
impacts and when it comes to technology
i think the more one of the more
interesting actually analyses comes from
neil postman who talks about the
ecological impact of tech for example
which is we're often incorrect when we
think about tech as being additive
we're way too i would say self-important
when we feel like oh tools come along
and we just use them strategically for
extra power they give us actually new
tools new technology
innovations tend to be ecological the
new technology comes in and the whole
way the world works changes
and so what you're talking about is a
great example of that we've been getting
a lot of these ecological changes driven
by new technology in the last let's say
25 years if we want to go back to the
beginning of email but certainly with
smartphones and social media
and that's a big threat i talk about too
because part of this dislocation this
lack of depth this shallowness has been
a consequence of new technology coming
in
in an emergent fashion changing the
ecology so it's not like people were
really planning to do it this way
we weren't ready for it and suddenly we
extend this metaphor
we've lost our old ecological niche and
feel adrift and our work is all
we're on email all day and work at home
we're just scrolling phones all day
we're anxious we don't feel rooted to
anything
tech played a big role in that so it's
time to actually stand back
like naturalist and study this ecologies
here like okay the world has changed we
need to rebuild our lives
what's the primary issue with email then
is there something wrong with the
technology itself
the primary issue is actually
neurological it's the cost of network
switching
so human beings their brains in
particular our attention systems are
very sequential
right what we're wired to do is to pay
attention to one thing and then we're
done
switch our attention to another thing
that switch can take some time and it
takes some energy it could take 5 10
15 minutes to really change your
cognitive context from
this over to that now if you're doing
one thing after another the way that
humans operated for
most of our existence that switching
costs it gets lost in the noise it's not
a big deal you know i'm
i'm working on this for two hours and
then i switch over to go fix the wagon
for the next hour the fact that there
was 10 minutes up front before i really
got
locked in on my wagon fixing who cares
right
email and here's the issue is
the checking of these inboxes or the
checking of slack
or the checking of teams triggers a
network switch
your mind is seen a completely different
context that's very salient because it
involves communication from other people
and it involves urgency so our mind
immediately begins to trigger a network
switch when we see an inbox
but then we wrench our attention back to
what we're doing before that network
switch can complete we don't sit there
for 10 minutes what we're really doing
is just seeing oh
did my boss write back about what time
the meeting is so we initiate network
switches
turn our attention back to the main
thing try to abort that network so it
should go back to the previous cognitive
context
before we can get back there we go back
and look at the inbox again it is these
repeated partial network
switches from a neurological standpoint
that is a disaster
it reduces our ability to think clearly
it causes
cognitive exhaustion this is why by two
o'clock in the afternoon most office
workers kind of give up on doing
anything hard and it makes us anxious
so as a tool fine smtp is a great
protocol pop3 is a great protocol
if i want to send you a file or
broadcast out a memo i'd rather use
those
protocols than a fax machine or memos
the thing that's killing us is this
style of work that email enabled
that requires us to keep checking and
that has been a disaster
so the primary issue is that it forces
you to switch attention
from doing work to talking about doing
your work
and then back again yeah and even if
even if what you're doing in your inbox
is very critical and it's part of your
work it's the network switching having
to network switch that
much means you can't do anything that
well now the key distinction is
that is not a necessary side effect of
the tool of email
in fact email spread in the early 1990s
had nothing to do with that
email spread in the early 1990s to
replace the fax machine in the replace
voicemail which it did really well
it makes complete sense why it spread it
was a productivity silver bullet
for those purposes once it was in the
offices
we adopted this way of working that i
call the hyperactive hive find where we
said well now that we
can do very low friction fast digital
communication
why don't we just work everything out on
the fly with back and forth messaging
that's what causes all the contact
shifts because if i'm working everything
out with back and forth messaging
i have to keep tending these
conversations if i don't check my inbox
i'm grinding to a halt a lot of these
asynchronous back and forth
conversations and stuff doesn't get done
so it was really the adoption of this
hyperactive
hive mind workflow that followed spread
of email
that began to cause all the problems so
if you get rid of the hyperactive hive
mind workflow
it's great that we have email because
again i don't want to have to fax you a
contract i want to send it to you
i don't want to send you the new menu in
a memo folder for the
office cafeteria i want to see see it to
you email is not the problem
the hyperactive hivemind workflow that
email makes possible
that's really the culprit and i think
that is the thing that has been causing
a lot of trouble in modern work right
now
why is context switching so suboptimal
and yet so tempting
is it hacking into something somewhere
in the
neurology or the psychology of how we
work
well so it's an important question right
because
when we think about distraction writ
large let's say digital distraction writ
large
there is often an aspect to this
conversation which is the addictive
impulse to check
but what i want to do here is actually
separate out two classes of distractions
that seem similar but there's different
underlying mechanisms going on
i want to separate the professional
distraction of i need to go back and
check my inbox
i need to go back and check slack i want
to separate that let's say from
i want to check my phone i want to look
at what's going on twitter i want to
look on what's going on
on social media i want to see what's on
youtube right let's separate those two
when it comes to the the stuff that's
happening on your phone this is what my
book digital minimalism is about
there is what's called a moderate
behavioral addiction usually at play
here
these tools have often been designed to
actually induce this behavior of
constant checking there's a lot of
aspects that go into that
so i think it is it is proper to use
even the framework of behavioral
addiction when thinking about why we
look at our phones so much
email and slack seem similar because we
look at it so much but the underlying
dynamic is different it's less because
there is an addictive impulse but more
because
if the hyperactive hive mind is how your
organization largely collaborates
you have to check it because if you
don't check it
you're falling behind on back and forth
conversations and it's going to slow
things down it's going to upset other
people
and that's why i've been pushing back on
using the perspective of addiction for
thinking about email
it's not an issue about irrational or
sub-optimal behavior
of the user in fact checking your inbox
all the time is basically your only
option
if this is the way your work actually
functions what we have to do here is
change the way that
you the underlying way that you actually
collaborate that we we don't fix the
email problem with individuals tweaking
their hacks we fix it by having
the whole team change the rules by which
they collaborate
otherwise it would just be get some
tiago forte course
or learn to batch process or do a david
allen
and and that would fix it but there's a
lot of people
listening and myself who have gone
knee deep in that world and yet
there's still this hyperactive hive mind
this relationship this expectation from
other people
which pulls you through it's almost like
it's almost like
if social media didn't have the
compulsive
uh the variable schedule reward but did
have
people waiting on the app to see if you
were going to clear your notifications
all the time
that's kind of what it's like and
and uh there would be professional
ramifications if you didn't
know what i mean kind of and i think the
a very useful analogy here is like if
you're in a boat
and you're out on a lake and it's
filling with water the the equivalent of
this metaphor of
better productivity tools and taking
online courses about productivity and
buying these tools it's like okay here's
what i'm going to do i'm going to i'm
going to buy better buckets to bail this
with
i'm going to take a an online course
subscribe to superhuman we'll get on the
waiting list for superhuman yeah yeah
yeah zyto cast and bucket
my bucket technique's going to get
better right like i'm going to have you
know more efficiency
what you need to do is uh plug the
bottom of the boat right
that's what the issue is this is what's
happening with our inboxes uh
we need to stop trying to bail the
messages out of there quicker we have to
change the underlying processes that are
putting those messages into the inbox in
the first place if you do that right
you don't really need much productivity
tools or hacks or thinking to handle
your inbox well because it'll be
relatively trivial to do
well i mean as a perfect example your
approach to digital minimalism
you have a limited slippery slope of how
much social media can
impact you if you don't have social
media
yeah if you get at the root cause
yeah if you know like so i don't use any
social media so i don't have to worry
about it
uh the people i know who are digital
minimalist and use social media so
they're deploying it in a
minimalist fashion they also are much
better off because if you're deploying
social media in a minimalist fashion
that means you're deploying it for
particular uses
and that changes the whole equation
because if you know oh i'm using this
tool for this
then it's much much easier to put guard
rails around everything else right so if
you say well yeah
i'm i'm using uh it's a real example
from from someone i know he's an
instagram fitness influencer so
uh instagram is very important to his
business right i mean
posting he's a very muscular very
muscular guy and he needs to post photos
of him doing athletic thing or videos or
however however instagram works right
but when he knows okay here's why i use
instagram because if we put these photos
on the schedules
it this is it helps this business it's
important to me here's why i'm using it
once he knows exactly why he's using it
then he can optimize how he uses it and
his big hack was
i'm not going to use the phone on the
camera we're actually going to they use
better gopros and use better cameras
and my team then takes the photos and
on a desktop post them to instagram on a
regular schedule and not having
instagram on my phone means and i'm
speaking in the
from the perspective of the influencer
now it means that i'm not going to be
distracted all the time by this like
going through see what everyone's up to
and yet i'm still getting all the power
out of it because once i know why i'm
using it
i can figure out how best to use it
how much are people checking email
so the one study i cite says once every
six minutes
another study i cite says about 126
messages sent and received a day which
works out to something actually quite
similar i just summarized that all as
basically constantly
and that was sort of average knowledge
workers i was using rescue time right
yeah so rescue time is a great data set
because they have these tens of
thousands of users and i talked to their
ceo when i was working on this book
they realized at some point they had
great data so they hired a real
professional data scientist and
let her just get her hands into that
data and they produced all these great
reports
but it's backed up i talked about
there's observational workplace
ethnographies where they actually go
into workplaces and look over people's
shoulders
there's other studies where they go into
workplaces and temporarily
put monitoring software on computers and
all these numbers work out to be about
the same there's certain
points in the day where you can't check
email like you're literally in the
middle of something where you're away
from your computer
outside of those moments people rarely
go more than a handful of minutes
without at least doing a quick check but
the quick checks are just as damaging as
spending 20 minutes because it
initiates the network switch and it's
the initiation that kills you
not how long you spend afterwards the
initiation kills you
i had stephen cutler on the show a
little while ago do you know who that is
yes i know slow research collective guy
okay begin to flow um and he
would talk out right the art of
impossible dude you would
you would love it i highly highly
recommend you should really consider
getting him on the show i don't know
whether you do
how often you do guests but man he he
blew me away he's fantastic dude
and um he was talking
about because he understands the biology
right he's not bothered with psychology
he just wants to get straight into
how the body works and um he was talking
about the most
common thing that knocks people out of
flow is an emotion
so if you sense any emotion whether that
be an impulsive happiness or sadness or
anger or discomfort or whatever it might
be
that will just knock you out of flow and
if you think it takes a while to you've
got to get the brain waves at the
the balance between delta and theta or
something is the correct brainwave state
that biologists have found that's where
the neuroscience of flow and
so on and so forth you've got to do all
this work to get yourself into this
optimal state
and just a little bit of an emotion not
only gives you all of the pain of the
context switching and then takes time
for you to get back into
uh rhythmically kind of how it feels but
flow this
peak performance state that we're all
desperately trying to chase where you
get your
110 output done it's it's writing words
that you can only write when you're in
that position
and you've just lost it because the
compulsion to check email
or you've left notifications on or
whatever it might be
yeah i mean if you wanted to design what
are the
the worst possible things you could
expose yourself to when trying to get in
flow or do something
meaningful and deep probably email and
social media would be what you would
come up with like if you were a mad
scientist saying like my
my goal is not to take over the world
but to reduce productivity as much as
possible
those would be what you would design
because what do you get with email it's
it's
communication from other people that is
often
urgent and introduces uh unsatisfiable
in the moment demands you're exposing
yourself to things that people you know
need that you can't get to them right
now and then you try to turn your
attention back
good luck social media is all built
around right now most of the platforms
this type of emotional valency right
trying to trigger various emotions right
so again that is also designed like a
mad scientist would do so let's expose
you to like some
some outrage or funny whatever it is
right really quickly
really distilled just like kotler talks
about right so
those two things are like if you work
backwards from
his book and said how can i minimize
your output i would say okay here's what
i want you to do
every five minutes or so look at one of
these two things
and yet this is how most people in the
knowledge economy work and it is 50
of the us economy we're like we're fine
with this let's just let's just work
with our brains create value with our
brains but set up an environment that is
the worst possible way to do it
it would be like if in the 1920s we were
running auto factories with the lights
off
right and people were putting steering
wheels where the the tires should go and
we forgot to put the roofs on and we
said yeah but you know we're saving on
the electric bill
or something right it's like it's crazy
people are like this is insane
but we have this blind spot because we
don't really understand knowledge work
that well
yet and it's hard to see inside a brain
where you can see physical stuff you can
see that i'm missing the tire but it's
hard to see what's going on in the brain
we're working in the worst possible way
and we seem to just shrug our shoulders
and
i guess this is just what work is and
there's an absurdity to it
you talk about the similarities between
the industry and the revolution
of industry about 100 years ago and sort
of where we're at with the knowledge
economy now can you talk about
that relationship and similarities well
there's often a lot of work that's
required
when you have a technological revolution
that intersects with commerce
it's not night and day right it's not
here's the electric dynamo
next week we've completely rebuilt how
factories work it's not okay here's the
first car factory
next week we have the assembly line it
takes a long time for us often to figure
out what's the best way to actually
integrate new technology into commerce
and i talk about in the book in
particular car manufacturing
it took about 25 years to figure out how
to do this right
and to get from building cars using the
convenient and simple craft method
to the inconvenient real pain tons of
overhead annoying
assembly line method that was also 10x
faster that took time
and a lot of experimentation i think
something similar needs to happen in
knowledge work so right now we're
working in
the the simplest easiest most flexible
possible way the first thing we came up
with which is the hyperactive hive mind
well let's just everyone can be
connected
let's make communication as fast and low
friction as possible we'll just work
things out on the fly
that's fine it was a good first step but
inevitably we're going to evolve
we're going to evolve to better ways to
actually work we're going to turn the
lights back on
inside the metaphorical auto factory but
the main thing to remember about this
evolution in the industrial sector is
that it took time and it was a pain
the best way to build cars was harder
than the easiest way
the best way to build cars had a lot of
false starts a lot of experimentation it
was a huge pain for the employees was
you had to hire more managers it was
very difficult to figure out how to make
this thing work but it was worth it
because it took the man hours required
to produce a model t from 12.5 down to
93 minutes
and so that's the main thing i want
people to take away from that metaphor
is that yes
knowledge work is going to get more
sophisticated we're going to get more
out of our minds it's going to be less
frustrating but the ways we work is
probably going to have more rules and
guides and systems and hard edges it's
not going to be easy to get right at
first and that's just what the evolution
of business looks like
wasn't it a statistic that henry ford
became the richest man in america five
years after he
perfected the production line process
yeah and the company became the biggest
in the world
yeah but it was a pain i mean just
imagine if you were in the ford factory
and you were you're
working in the ford factory before this
experimentation began
the way they were building cars would
have made complete sense they would put
a chassis up on two saw horses you would
be part of a team that would sit on that
chassis and build a car
it made complete sense and to have a
factory you just have lots of chassis
and lots of teams
you know and you're like yeah how else
would you build a car this is very
convenient it's very flexible
i understand it now imagine the assembly
line comes along now we're gonna have
these chains moving with gearing systems
we have to build custom tools that can
come in and bore
12 holes at a time into the engine block
so that we can move it from here to here
faster
and it keeps breaking and this part's
going faster than this part and the
whole thing stops and you had to hire
all these managers and engineers just to
get it working
you must have been like this is the most
annoying thing this is not at all
convenient this makes no sense
can't we just sit here and build cars
and then it became the biggest company
in the world and became the richest man
in the world because the right the best
way to do things is not
not often the same as what's the easiest
what's the most convenient
are you familiar with rory sutherland
the vice chairman of ogilvy big gruff
british man and he talks like this and
everything's a bit [ __ ] [ __ ]
isn't it uh he's one of the smartest
behavioral economists on the planet he's
a wonderful guy
he's been on the show twice and he's
always said
for years and years email would be far
better if it cost five pence
every time that you had to send one to
just add that little bit of friction
and i think you talk about this as well
people use
email for all manner of malign intents
because the cost to do it is
so low you get an email i do this all
the time i find it
if if i can't be bothered to answer the
central question of the email sometimes
i'll ask a much more superficial
question
to just be like no bang back over to you
it's your side of the net until i can
then be bothered to deal with it
or the inevitable unnecessary
confirmation that goes around when
there's
10 people cc'd in in a big group thread
and you're like all this is doing is
just throwing this thread back to the
top of
so yeah i think um because
it is so frictionless which is what
makes it a great communication tool
it also creates this slippery slope you
talk about um
is it we don't understand
what happens to a technology when the
cost goes down to zero or when the
friction goes down to zero it causes
some
strange externalities yeah you gotta be
careful about
very low friction and i i think that's
absolutely is what happened with email
and we
we can document this right i mean i one
of the stories i got from a
researcher a behavioral organizational
behavioral psychologist i talked about
in the
book was this story about where they
came into this office and ran an
experiment where they took
12 people off email for a week with no
prep just like you're off email for a
week let's see what
happened and she told me like one of the
interesting stories here is there's this
one guy
one of the 12 and he had been really
complaining because his boss would
bother him so much with these quote
unquote urgent emails right like
what about this can you do this what's
happening here and this guy's job
required him to set up a lab
because it was a research a research
company and it would take hours but it
would take
more than it needed to because his boss
would bother bother bother him with all
these
urgent emails so now the guy setting up
the lab is one of the 12
who's going to take one week away from
email because he's participating this
experiment
and the boss stopped bothering him
during that week and what made it
interesting is that the boss's office
was three doors down
so the friction for asking this guy to
do something
went from this and hitting send to let
me just open a door walk 10 feet
open a door and be like hey bob can you
do whatever that friction was enough to
basically
drastically reduce the amount of stuff
that this boss was bothering him with
because
zero friction is a really weird state i
think this is what's happening with zoom
meeting overload
during the pandemic if you're in an
office and you want to set up a meeting
it's a little bit of friction a there's
a little bit of friction if i have to go
and reserve the room and that takes a
little bit of time
but there's also more of a heightened
social capital friction because i got to
see those people come into the room
for the meeting i set up and they had to
go get their coffee and then they
they're not that happy necessarily they
have to be there and they're looking to
you like okay like you made me come all
the way over here what's going on
there's a little bit of friction in a
world of remote work and zoom it all
goes away
like i it's i just add your email
addresses and hit invite
boom and then you'll just show up at
this thing what happened
zoom took over people's entire day right
and you now have people during the
pandemic that were basically doing
zoom from nine to five people have
complained to me that like they don't
have time to go to the bathroom
during the day that's a problem because
there's not any breaks in between zoom
and then they have to do their real work
elsewhere so when you get rid of
friction very weird things happen
how does email make us miserable
well for one thing the idea of
communication from people we know
piling up and we're not responding to
them does not play well with our
paleolithic social circuits
like we treat we've evolved to treat
one-on-one relationships very carefully
and for good reason because if we don't
you know we're going to starve next time
we go through a famine and the tribe's
not going to share food with us because
they don't like us we take relationships
very seriously
that type of circuit is not well suited
for an inbox that's filling
now you can rationally tell yourself uh
don't worry about it this is not
tribe members and it's not urgent and
look we we have response time norms in
our company that says don't expect a
response within 12 hours so it's all
fine your rational brain can say this
but your deeper brain doesn't care it
says people need us we're ignoring them
just like you can't convince yourself
not to be hungry even if you explain
very carefully that you have dinner
reservations in two hours you're not
going to starve so i don't need this
warning about being hungry you're going
to stay hungry until you eat that food
the deep social circuits are going to
remain anxious about you ignoring people
until you answer them no matter what
your frontal cortex tells your mind
about
response time norm so it makes us
anxious because that makes us unhappy
the constant context shifting makes us
physiologically unhappy right i mean
it's a draining feeling that exhausts us
it can create anxiety like we
physiologically feel bad
if we're doing this unnatural rapid
context shifting
you do this over a long period of time
it's just straight up exhausting our
brains aren't
meant aren't meant to do this and then
three it's incredibly frustrating
because linguistic communication purely
written communication is incredibly
impoverished
we're really not good at communicating
just with written words we're much
better at having voice and tonation and
body language and then we get a lot of
information when communication is much
more accurate so
we are constantly being misunderstood
and constantly misunderstanding other
people which again as social creatures
is in itself very fraught and very
frustrating so you put all those things
together
it's not surprising that when they do
surveys on people's well-being
you see very strong correlations between
increased use with these
information communication technologies
and increased unhappiness
it's so interesting when you try and
take a first principles approach
to something that's so ubiquitous like
the vast majority of people that are
listening
they have to use email whatever it is
the the nurses so the nhs
is a really good example of this god
you'd have a field day
um one of my buddies is a recently
uh qualified medical doctor just gone
through his f1 and his f2 as a
student and now he's fully fledged and
um
some of the processes that they need to
go through to send an email downstairs
they can't take something downstairs
they have to wait for it to come back up
so they're physically and you know
there's people on beds waiting for them
so
i think when you can see these
individuals moving
you know they've got to locomote around
places and they're they're tethered
they're genuinely tethered as opposed to
this which is more
uh psychologically tethered i suppose
the impacts are crazy
it it really is i mean it's we're a
little bit
used to it in some sense that
all of this constant ongoing
communication this is just what work is
it's kind of that's the way it's been
that's the way it'll always be
and i think the biggest problem is and
until we identify that the hyperactive
hive
is the issue people's thought process is
okay i feel really overwhelmed with all
this communication but if
i just stopped using email it would be
terrible
and they're right like if the
hyperactive hive mind is how you
organize and you can't just not use
email
and the problem that's when people give
up though somebody's like well if i just
stopped using email
i wouldn't be able to talk nothing will
get done and i get fired and they're
right about that
but what they're wrong to do is just to
give up there you got to ask the next
question
okay why is it that the way we work
requires me to use so much email
and that's where you start to get
somewhere interesting so to me like the
first principle that unlocks everything
is stop talking about individuals habits
let's go underneath the covers and say
what are the different processes that
make up what we do
in my freelance business and my team and
my company whatever i do
what are the different processes i come
back to again and again these are the
things that make up my working life
great
how do we actually implement these
processes how do we move the information
around how do we communicate
and collaborate how do we reach
decisions what is our
actual explicit set of rules or guides
or systems for this one and for this one
and for this one and for this one
and until you actually do that the
default will just be the hyperactive
hive mine
will get overloaded with context
switches will all be miserable
but once you realize oh if i change the
underlying process how we implement it
that's generating all these unscheduled
messages in the first place
i can actually fix the problem and
that's the way to fix the problem
the underlying structure about how we
work needs to move away from unscheduled
messaging towards other things it might
be more of a pain the assembly line was
a pain
but is absolutely worth it if it gets
rid of these unscheduled messages is the
primary mean with by which we
collaborate
that's great from a god's eye view with
all of the perspective of not having to
be
in the trenches but if you're just some
nat desperately trying to
be a digital minimalist and a deep
worker and a world without email a
deep lifer uh it's a little bit more
difficult like
where are people supposed to start why
should they highlight
or what are the places that someone
could start to begin looking at the
process
principle so if if you're if you have no
say right like over other people you're
you're part of a team in a big company
you can still do this process just with
what you can control right so
you you literally start by saying what
are the different processes to make up
what i do in my job
and if you're not sure what those are
use your inbox to help you right
take one day and every time you get an
email message ask the question
what is the repeated process this email
is involved with it is connected to
what's the thing that i'm i do regularly
that this email is helping me make
progress on and you can use your inbox
to help figure out and literally write
down
i'm involved in scheduling client
meetings on a regular basis producing
white paper reports on new products i'm
involved in
thing after thing after thing now you
have this list of the different
processes you're involved with
ask the question for each not all at
once we'll start with the low-hanging
fruit and once that goes well we'll move
on to new ones
but take some of these processes and ask
the question given just what
i can control how do i want to implement
my involvement with this process in such
a way that it minimizes the number of
unscheduled messages required to
actually get this thing done
and looking at just what you can control
you can drastically reduce those
unscheduled messages and sometimes it's
very simple right sometimes it's just
there's a tool you can slot in there
right it's okay i have to set up a lot
of meetings with people
um that generates a lot of unscheduled
messages because we go back and forth so
i'm going to use scheduling software
one quick solution boom that saved you a
lot of unscheduled messages
sometimes you have a process you you
figure out some implementation that
you're not going to advertise as some
new sort of system you kind of
stealthily recruit people into it right
so you email someone okay
um we got to get this report out uh
here's what i suggest
i'll work on a draft on monday and by
close of business monday i'll put my
draft into this shared folder
then it's all yours if you have any
questions i have office hours tuesday at
noon so you can just stop by the office
or also i'm in the slack channel just
for office hours and
we can hash it out then and then just
get whatever you're doing
get it into the dropbox by close the
business on three
i'll then take a final look hey designer
who i've cc'd on this
whatever you see in that folder at the
end of day tuesday you can take it
format it put it live right it feels
like you're just sort of laying out a
plan and
you know just in the email people like
yeah sure what i'm glad there's a plan
whatever so i need to do this tomorrow
great i don't want to think about
anymore
you've just co-opted all those people
into an implementation of this process
that's going to get that report created
with
zero unscheduled messages so there's a
lot you can do
without having to uh make believers of
everyone without having to give everyone
a copy of my book and convince them to
read it there's a lot you can do
just from the perspective of an
individual once you know what it is
you're trying to do and once you know
that the objective is look at your
processes
adjust your implementation to reduce
unscheduled messages
the more you can do that the better your
life is going to get even if no one else
around you knows that you're doing that
and even if no one else around you is
even on board with that plan
the vast majority of the work that you
do after you've been in a job for
probably six months to a year is just
repetition done this before i know this
before and you realize this because when
you first step into a job you're
constantly asking people for advice
where does the
where do i get the media pack from and
how do i send a file to accounts and
what do we do when we need to schedule a
meeting in and all this sort of stuff
then after a while you're like you just
know it
so one of the principles here i think
that we can try and take away is okay
how can i automate as much of the
workflow of the things that i need to do
as possible how can i make it go
seamless
and yeah i think using your email inbox
over a extended period of time as an
identifier okay so
what's coming up consistently scheduling
its accounts it's asking for the dropbox
link or
whatever else it might be and focusing
on the attention capital
that should hopefully free us up because
we're not doing this constant context
switching it allows us to get more work
done that actually matters
yeah so that that's absolutely right i
mean the way i think about it is there's
there's two rough classes um
maybe three depending on how we want to
talk about but there's let's say there's
a small number of rough classes of what
these
optimized process implementations look
like one big class and there is
automation right
this is something where it's the same
steps every time like you're talking
about so if there's something you do in
your work where it's the same steps
every time like
this gets written it gets reviewed it
gets signed off on it gets formatted it
gets posted right it's the same steps
every time
you can automate that which means you
find a workflow that allows it to go
through those steps without ever
requiring someone to have to wait for a
message
unscheduled and then respond to it right
another class of things you might need
to optimize are one-off like oh we have
a new project
we have to work on so there's not some
steps that we it's always the same every
time but there what you want to focus on
is uh how can we structure where the
information goes and how we communicate
and collaborate about that information
right
so there it's probably going to be on
trello or asana or flow or base camp
let's get a place for the information to
live let's have these highly structured
meetings in which we can check in and
look at the information and
decide who's working on what you want to
structure when you talk about it where
the information
lives the third class roughly speaking
in the book i talk about are protocols
where it's literally like a a type of
back and forth communication that
happens
on a frequent basis and how you can put
in place protocols there that actually
makes that
require much fewer unscheduled messages
so instead of clients just
calling sending you emails whenever they
have an issue you maybe have we've set
up
no no we have this weekly check-in call
and we immediately post a written
summary of everything we committed to do
during that call
but you have to wait till the next call
if you have a question right so these
are kind of the three classes of what
these all look like but the key thing is
what you're trying to get away from is
the context switch that's the
productivity poison
the best proxy for context switching is
unscheduled messages so
unscheduled messages is what generates
all those context switches because you
have to keep checking while you're
waiting for that message to come
be willing to do more work more work and
spend more time
if the trade-off is less on scheduled
messages that's how painful it is so i
would rather
i would rather spend 10 minutes to try
to list out in an email okay here is all
the times i'm available for the next
three weeks because
uh i don't want to go back and forth to
set up a meeting with because that's
gonna generate five unscheduled messages
i'd rather spend five to ten minutes now
and give you 20 options then send you a
30 second message right now it's like
yeah when are you free but no there's
going to be five more interruptions over
the next couple of days to set it up the
context switching are sort of
so much more dramatically costly than
actually just spending more time in the
moment
that i really like to emphasize that
you're not trying to optimize time
you're not trying to optimize
convenience be willing to work harder
and have more complexity and spend more
time if it saves you from the need to
have to do unscheduled messaging
and this is because there is a there's a
power law
effect going on with the context
switching right it's not just the time
that because
if we were going for pure time if
context switching
didn't have this disproportionate impact
on our ability to focus
i imagine that most of these arguments
or some of these arguments at least
would have a lot less veracity be like
well we could go about this thing but
actually considering i can just send off
an email in 30 seconds
i need to get 20 emails worth of time
saving because that but it's not
just the 30 seconds of the email it's
the subsequent time that goes over the
top
i think that little story is a good
microcosm
for kind of the uh the entire world
of email use right that everybody every
organization and then into between
organizations as well
everybody has had the opportunity to
step back from the urgent
and look at process protocol and
whatever the third one was
i've forgotten uh to look at those
things and think right how can i
how can i change these what can i do now
let's just
let's just take a month off let's take a
month off from clients let's
let's not have any business coming in
but know that for the next five years
we're going to have
every workflow under the sun done and
we're going to be working at 2x capacity
yeah yeah well hey if we have this and
if we have to change it every month we
have to change it every month right
yeah still worth it right if we have to
evolve we miss things new things come up
great spend the time to do it
spend a half day a week you're still
gonna end up better off like we're gonna
spend three hours a week doing nothing
but
meeting and talking about our workflows
and trying to make them better and
reduce the context switching you would
still be better off you could spend a
day a week
and probably still end up better off but
we'll go to a four day week because all
we do on friday
is figure out how to reduce messages you
would still end up better off that's how
that's how
disproportionate the cost is there's an
inherent laziness isn't that that you
talk about to do with using
email because it's so frictionless and
it doesn't actually require you to do
much
in the way of abstract thinking there's
no metacognizance required it's just
brain
fingers send brain fingers send over and
over and over again
yeah and we play we play responsibility
hot potato with email which
which you you mentioned earlier which is
where basically
i feel a little bit of stress or anxiety
that this thing is my responsibility on
my brain
if i shoot you an email that says like
hey what about this or thoughts question
mark
it relieves that temporarily it is now
on your plate right because i've
that the email is in your inbox and i've
freed up that space i feel a little bit
better
you get the thoughts question mark email
you're like ah crap the hot potatoes on
my plate now right you're like okay so
um
uh remind me again what this was about
sin boom off your plate you've thrown
the hot potato on the my plate now and
now i have this thing in my head i'm
like uh
let's chat about it when are you free
boom now it's off my plate right and we
do this with everything
um because we don't like the discomfort
of having things on our plate this is
what happens when we try to keep up with
an inbox that's overflowing it's like
just getting it off my plate i don't
care if i know it's coming back i just
want that relief in the moment
but again the response to all this is
basically too bad right i
work by definition is the application of
force against something that is
otherwise on rest
it is by definition something that
requires effort it's what
work actually is so trying to minimize
effort is not a very good
metric when you're trying to say what's
going to make me more effective at work
what's going to make my company more
successful
what's going to make my what's going to
make my company grow we have to figure
out what's the right way to do this
and then we have to do it because we
want to be successful in what we're
doing
and work is effort it's actually
synonymous
what are some of the best practices for
people who have to send emails
what are some of the ways that they can
create and send emails that can't be
automated
well so if you're if you're thinking
about unscheduled messaging as the
poison
then it really changes the way you think
about your communication so now when
you're communicating with people
you're seeing the bigger picture here oh
there's some objective we are trying to
get to
it's going to require some collaboration
coordination how can we do this with a
minimum of messages and once you have
that mindset it really drastically
changes
what you send and what you suggest you
know so you have to know what it is
you're trying to optimize so so one
thing you get is more of these
process-oriented emails like the example
i gave about producing the document
where
it's not just thoughts question mark
you're laying out okay
here's the plan to get us from here to
us being done and i'm laying out a plan
here that's sensible
and doing a little bit of work up front
but i'm going to reduce
unnecessary messages along the way you
do more of that
you also start to do more fallback type
things i'm a big believer for example in
office hours set times on set days where
you're always available for anyone to
stop by
in person or virtually depending on what
the circumstance is
and you can move more and more core
quick coordination questions or
discussion
to those great grab me at my next office
hours we'll get into it boom you start
sending that message a lot more
each one of those messages where you say
just grab me at my next office hours
you may have just saved a 10 message
back and forth conversation
maybe doesn't sound so bad but that's
five messages in there that you have to
wait to wait for and respond to pretty
quickly right because if you wait a day
to respond this conversation will take
two weeks
but that means you might do ten inbox
checks for each of those five messages
because
you're checking checking checking
waiting for it so you may have saved
50 inbox checks in one day
just by saying this is great grab me at
my next office hours right like
the the savings are really big so
process oriented emails
defaulting to things like office hours
or status meetings
these are the types of best practices
you see once you realize the whole goal
here is not about
clearing out your inbox quicker not
about expectations
it's about unscheduling messages like
that
messages that are going to come into
some unspecified time that i'm going to
need to respond to relatively quickly
that is what i am trying to get away
from it completely changes the type of
things you do
you use do you sit in a zoom room
i know that's one of the potential
solutions that you could just have a
cals zoom room and there's the link and
anybody can just drop in and drop out as
they need during this window on this day
yeah so so there's there's three things
i've seen there's uh because academics
we do
where office hours come from our world
right so uh virtually speaking zoom
rooms is a big one you actually set up a
waiting room
and then you bring people in one on one
so if someone shows up while you're
talking to someone else they don't show
up in the middle of your conversation
they're in the waiting room and then you
can you can bring them in
slack channels i've also seen right it's
like an office hour slack channel
if people want to type instead of
talking to you i will be in this channel
during these hours so jump over there we
can go and there'll be a transcript and
searchable so that's nice too
and then uh door open cl door open you
know
in person office hours are fantastic
professors i
rely on this incredibly heavily in my
life as a college professor like a lot
of professors do we we've kind of
perfected this idea
especially for working with students
it's like sounds great sounds
interesting
come to my office hours right and and
the students like it because it's
incredibly clear great i know what i
need to do
and we like it because if we had to keep
up 35 different ongoing conversations
with 35 different students
it would be untenable so yep zoom slack
and your door open
what are the main objections that you've
heard from people when you've suggested
that they implement a reduction in email
so where you where you really start to
get the objections is before you're able
to get into the
details of what the real issue is so
if you just see for example the title of
my book people who live
in the world of the hyperactive hive
mind say any reduction in email would
make me worse at my job and they're
right
if the way you organize your work is
with back and forth messaging the more
time you're away from messaging
the worse you do at your job and so
there's a lot of objections around that
once you get past that though and say no
no it's the hyperactive high fine itself
that's the problem we need to find ways
to collaborate that has much less
unscheduled messaging
there's been almost no complaint i i've
i've actually been surprised i thought
there would be more pushback from from
uh tech types or some people they're
like look no no this is good like this
this rapid back
back and forth is uh it's an advanced
state of human existence as we really
are able to make quicker decisions
there's just a universal detestation of
this and maybe it's because the pandemic
made the hyperactive hive mind more
hyperactive
but once i actually explain what i'm
talking about here people say yeah i
hate that
that thing great good i'm glad let's
let's figure out a way to get
people know it's hard people are quick
to say it's not going to be obvious how
to change this like that i'll get
but there's a lot less protestation than
i thought i
i think we're at a point now where we we
no longer think this is high tech
we just are frustrated with it you
touched on something earlier on
about uh the trying to be incognito
when you're suggesting these small
changes and kind of bringing people in
surreptitiously
i think that's quite important because
one of the things
i imagine that some people might have as
an objection
is i don't want to be the black sheep
that's coming in here
like with my blue blocking glasses on
and my special
gel wrist pad for my keyboard so i can
type at 0.5 percent faster
you just don't want to be that guy and i
i've heard you talk previously about
how um blanket email responses
saying i'm not available or i'm busy or
i only check email at these times that
that's a bad idea
and also steaming in and saying right
guys i'm not going to be dealing with
email and i'm not going to be doing this
because it kind of just waves a flag
above your head and
socially we have to remember that we are
dealing with
non-rational other beings and if you
steam in they go
bloody hell carl's bought his light up
keyboard in again with him and he's not
replying to emails until 4 p.m every day
but you can i suppose that the social
element of this needs to be more
uh subtle yeah it's really important
the the key psychological element is
relevant to these type of changes is
buy-in
right if people are involved
in a decision being made that affects
them then they're much more likely of
course to buy in to that decision
as opposed to being felt like that
change is imposed on them
so if you have a team and ultimately in
a perfect world this is the right scale
at which to make these changes
is at the team level not the individual
and not the organization but at the team
level if you have a team making changes
let's here's how we're going to work on
clients here's how we're going to work
on reports and we're going to try to
minimize the hyperactive pipeline
if everyone on the team is working
together and everyone has to say
then yeah you want to be super clear
about it and write it down we're going
to check in on it every two weeks
because everyone has buy-in
right we all have buy-in because we're
all involved what happens is when an
individual makes changes
that is going to affect your life right
because i now you know
i don't use email you're going to have
to go into my trello board and whatever
you're affecting my life but i had no
say in that
like this was just your decision that is
from a psychological perspective very
fraught and you're almost certainly
going to get pushback
so that's why i suggest in the book that
you should make changes on your own you
should see your own processes and try to
reduce back and forth messages but don't
advertise
because when you advertise changes that
you unilaterally made even though they
are better
the people around you say here is
something that impacts me that i had no
say in and the human instinct there no
matter how good it is no matter how much
is probably going to make even their
life better their instinct is i don't
know about this i don't like this
and so i always say don't advertise you
know don't put out an autoresponder
explaining when you're not going to be
checking emails just
check emails when you need to check
emails if someone complains then you can
explain it to them
but don't give people a reason to be
upset that they didn't realize they
needed to be upset
wait till they're actually upset and
then try to assuage them because you'll
figure out most people don't care
a reader sent me the other day an auto
responder he's like okay this is the
hive mind
gone to a new extreme someone had it was
like a temporary
power outage or something but basically
the autoresponder was like um
the the power had to get turned off
temporarily by the the repair crew so
i'm not gonna be on email for the next
hour
he's like okay this is the hyperactive
hive mind push through the extreme where
you feel like even if you're just gonna
be away from an hour you need to explain
to people
uh it's a sign that we're in trouble so
yeah i'm a big believer if people didn't
have a say in the change don't advertise
it
so if you're doing it as a team everyone
should be on the same page that's great
if you're doing as an individual just do
it and you know if someone complains you
can
finesse that later what are the smallest
first steps that people can take to
implement this into their lives what can
they go away and
do this evening or tomorrow well so
you have to start by listing out all the
processes the list can grow but like
here's all the things i do regularly
and then look for the lowest hanging
fruit like
what is the thing on here that would be
easiest for me to overhaul and reduce
unscheduled messages
for most people in most office jobs is
going to be meeting scheduling
right i am going to use a scheduling
tool
or if it's socially unacceptable to use
a scheduling tool i'm literally going to
have like a text file with
available times on it that i just paste
into emails and then you know once
someone takes one i just take it off the
text file right
however you need to do that that's
usually the lowest hanging fruit
and it has a disproportionate a
disproportionate advantage because again
the example i gave before
each meeting you try to set up over
email might be ten messages five of
which you have to wait for each of which
requires 10
email inbox checks so each each time you
send out a scheduling link instead of
saying when do you want to meet you
might save
50 email inbox checks in a short period
of time so people are often surprised
it seems minor and yet they feel much
much more relieved all right so that's
low hanging fruit
office hours i think is another low
hanging fruit process because there's a
lot of different processes out there
that you can
vastly improve simply by pushing people
towards office hours
and so i think that's a that those are
becoming more acceptable i think that's
another
uh that's another easy thing to set up
so list all the processes
look for some low-hanging fruit to get
the taste in your mouth those are two
things that will probably show up once
you're looking for what are the easiest
changes i can make
i like the text file or the spreadsheet
that you copy across and delete out of
i have to say i would be a prime
candidate
for using calendly or some other sort of
scheduling software
doing 150 podcast episodes a year
so three a week plus guesting on other
people's shows calendly should be
my solution but i know when i ask
someone when they're available
and i get a reply with a calendar link
there is something in me
that feels a little bit i just don't
like the process of doing it and i think
you touched on it it there
but you basically get the beauty of a
calendly link
with a little bit of a copy and paste
you could keep it on a note you could
even make it as an autofill in alfred or
something else like that
um yeah that's it that's a really a
really nice solution
can you talk me i just want to say real
quick remember the cost
the proper cost balance oh it's going to
take me a minute
instead of 10 seconds to keep this list
and send it out but you're saving
potentially 50 inbox checks each of
which has a 10 to 15 minute impact on
your concentrate so when you know the
cost
you're willing to do a lot more on the
front end so if lillian from penguin
random house is listening she'll know
that the reason that she's getting big
fat lists of dates off me for all of the
upcoming authors
is going to be because cal told me to do
it can you talk me
but by the way like lily and i have a
good system because you know i know
you've got your spreadsheet right and
she goes because we're promoting this
book she had that she had to approve
because but we have that we have this
thing and she puts it in the shared doc
and
uh you know and i check it twice a week
and uh yeah anyways once you know what
you're optimizing
and i didn't do it for my uk publisher
because i don't usually do a ton of
publicity in the uk so like
it's i won't bother but then the book
was popular in the uk so
we were booking a lot of a lot more uk
publicity with my uk publisher
and we didn't have this system in place
night and day right
um it's it's like well what about this
time what about that back and forth and
so is this great a b
test you know we're doing the exact same
thing two different teams in two
different ways i'm like oh
man uh that was the lillian method
is so much better you should have called
it that she'd love that
she would what's your personal email
handling setup i've heard you say that
you've got six different email addresses
and a number of other processes
can you just give us like a high-level
view of how cal newport sets his emails
up
yeah i have a multiple addresses so
in my role as a professor i have a
sort of a general university address
this is where university business comes
through right this is the announcements
and stuff like this and
uh and then i have a separate university
address i use for
my collaborators right so people i'm
actually working on research so i
separate that
and then in the writing world um i have
that i have an address called
interesting
for my readers to send me tips and links
and books that i might find interesting
and then i have a couple secret
addresses i use once i'm doing back and
forth for someone but i don't i don't
want to be public facing
and so i have a relatively and have a
personal address that i use with my
friends and family
a lot of different addresses all have
their own inboxes and it allows me to
customize how and when i use them so
some of these addresses i have what i
call sender filters on them
so if you're going to send a message to
interesting you're gonna see there's a
description of
what to expect which is like i love to
see links and books and articles
i do read all these messages i basically
never respond like so i can set
expectations
is that an auto responder no it's so
it's actually
uh on my contact page so for me
okay here's the address and i describe i
describe it right there
and if you go to my contact page for
example i it's channels right there's no
general purpose address on my website
right there's okay you wanna send me
links go here you it it's like a
publicity
interview type thing go here which which
will go to like a publicity team you
want to talk
a talk and book before talk well go here
right so you see
you can slot yourself into the proper
channel and you know what to expect
some things that people want my
attention for there's no channel for
them
but they're not mad at me i'm not
ignoring them they're not sending it to
a general purpose address that i'm then
ignoring them at there's just
no outlet for them uh descended and so
psychologically i think that's
it's much much better and then when and
how i check these inboxes
to me that's less interesting because
what i'm constantly trying to do is
figure out
what are the underlying processes that
are putting messages into these inboxes
in the first place how can i improve
them to have less unscheduled messages
so it's for me it's not a game of how
often or when i check it it's making
sure
that i don't have too much pressure in
any of them if there's a
ton of emails coming into my one of my
personal
writer addresses because lillian and i
are trying to schedule a lot of
interviews
the question is not how often do i check
this inbox is oh we need a better system
so i don't have so many of these back
and forth unscheduled messages right if
there's a bunch of student emails coming
in because a lot of students have
questions about their grades coming up
because of the midterm i say okay
what matters here is not how often i
check this inbox it's i need to talk to
my tas and set up a system where they
have access to the grade spreadsheet and
they can send a message to the ta
and get this information let's figure
out a way to do this without just a lot
of unscheduled messages so
that's always my mindset with my various
inboxes is not
when and how i check it i mean when i do
my time block planning i
i put email time in there some days i
don't check at all some days i'm
trying to catch up on things it's the
process oriented thinking that matters
for me
are there too many messages in here when
i check it how do i make sure that's not
the case
next time i check it that's the way i'm
thinking
it's so counterintuitive to have
multiple email addresses
and yet i think of all of the things
that we've gone through today
everything we've said what is a high
upfront cost that you can pay to make
the downstream
context switching cost reduced just
making an email address for online
purchases
like just that just for when you buy
some new clothes or
diy equipment or your right move alerts
or whatever the hell it is that you've
got going on
it seems honestly i've i've heard you
talk about this before during my
research for
this talk and i thought i'm such an i
considered myself a sophisticated
digital individual
and i realized just how idiotic it is
that i use
a main email for friends for business
for podcast scheduling for all manner of
different things
like that's that should be something
that everybody can go away and do today
you could make the same email address
that you have and just add a number one
two or three on the end of it and there
you go there's your three inboxes
and what's it take how long does it take
on gmail to do that five minutes
maybe less you don't have to do that you
know you can for some things you can
just do
uh any term and a plus sign and then
your
normal gmail address and and it'll send
it to your normal gmail address and you
can filter it so you can do sign up
i think this still works sign up plus
and then your normal gmail address
and just use that every time you you do
any online shopping or have to give your
register for anything and would you
set up auto rules in yeah and then you
set up a filter in gmail that takes that
and uh tags it and so this is what i do
so i have some of these addresses all
come into gmail
i was going to say how do you how do you
then what's the infrastructure on the
on the internal end yeah so i have i
have filter rules that auto label them
right and and then auto archive so
there's a couple things that one thing i
do which is
which is considered a centric but i've
been doing this for years and years is
everything that comes to my inbox is
marked as red
i do not like this idea of like unread
and read messages
and you can let these things pile up so
i make everything just look the same
it's all in red so it's like this is not
a storage facility
you know handle things and get it out of
here i'm you can't you don't have the
advantage of new things are going to be
black and so
are you archiving quite aggressively
then yeah and then i archive quite
aggressively so so things get
a filter rule will apply a label and
then it archives
and then i go to the different labels to
see so actually i put most things
through a gmail account but everything's
auto archived and auto labeled
and then you see the list of labels on
the side they're kind of these are my
inboxes right so if i click on
the label for you know georgetown
collaborators
it'll then show me everything tagged
with the georgetown collaborator so
it's my inbox for that particular
address but this means i can filter
things even beyond
uh just addresses too like well i know
anything that comes from this person
so like i have an administrative inbox
which is
all the sign up stuff and newsletters
and it i
barely glance at this thing and it's the
bulk of my emails goes into that inbox
what really happens is they're labeled
without an archive and if i click on
that label i can see them all
um but yeah so that that's the way
that's the way i handle it but there's a
lot of different ways you can do it
honestly i think having completely
separate accounts is probably a little
better
like because you want the real context
switch protection
of okay i i need to go see if there's
amazon order shipped i'm
i'm logging into account that's just yes
so you want to silo yourself
into different operating
modes yes and the more that you can do
that yeah here's my friends let me log
into this account
here's my business account let me login
this account uh here's my internal
business account like
in your situation might be like oh
here's my external facing business
account where i'm i'm interacting with
guests
that we're trying to book or this or
that and so when i'm there and i log
into that account
that's all i'm i'm just in that world
i'm not seeing
something from my friend that i'm not
seeing something from amazon i'm not
seeing something my mom said like oh i'm
just in the world right now of dealing
with guests it really makes a difference
because of the context switching costs
dude there are people listening to this
that are rubbing their hands with glee
and waiting to get home to their laptop
tonight to set these up i'm gonna
i'm going to 100 take that on i
i appreciate the principles i think the
principles and everything else is a
fantastic thin end of the wedge to get
the buy-in and to understand the context
of why context switching is bad
but i think that on the back end is is
like a really
a really cool solution for a lot of this
i hope that it's
going to help a lot of people i had the
last question actually about um
is actually moving back to digital
minimalism and this is something
more behaviorally that you may have
stumbled on i wanted to know how people
can start a
sort of a deeper more digitally minimal
journey
if they've got hard embedded habits
around how they use their devices
but there's no unlinking those synapses
that myelin is down hard
how do they get past those existing
routines and this could work for email
as well
well i mean in digital minimalism i
suggest 30 days
i see okay you got to commit to 30 days
away from all these optional personal
technologies right so that's your
commitment 30 days where i'm not on
social media
i'm not on youtube i'm not on online
news
um you know 30 days okay then during
those 30 days
some of this is unwiring the synapses
some of this is this sort of
detoxing effect but the thing that makes
those 30 days successful is if you
aggressively
reflect an experiment to figure out what
do i really want to do with my time in
my life
right the aggressive experimentation
reflection is what allows you to finish
those 30 days and say
here's what i really want to spend my
time doing and now i can rebuild from
scratch here's the tools i'm going to
use i'm going to use them to service
these things i care about
and everything else everything that was
not an answer to this question of what's
the best way to use technology to
service these things i care about
i'm not going to use anymore that is
much more sustainable right because then
what happens as you're going forward is
that you're committed to a positive
vision of what you want your life to
look like
that is something that's very
sustainable what doesn't work is if you
try to just minimize negative
you say i spend too much time on
instagram i'm just going to try to use
instagram less or i'm going to take 30
days off from instagram
the somehow feel better and then i'm
going to resolve to use instagram less
trying to reduce a negative is often not
that effective
committing to supporting a positive is
so if you come out of the other side of
these 30 days with this new vision of
here's how i spend my time i do this
this and this and here's how i use tools
to help this
then it's much easier to ignore the tool
that doesn't fit into that picture
the maybe you used to use tic tac a lot
but now you're like you know i have this
vision i love and it makes me feel good
about how i'm living
and tick tock didn't have any role in
this vision so why would i go do that
i'm much more interested in continuing
to
live this deep structured life to get
after it to do the things i really
figured out i want to do so that's what
i recommend 30 days
it's not a detox it's a time for
actually reimagining what you want your
life to be like
have you considered that longer term
probably in
40 or 50 years time we're going to see
i used my phone too much or i spent too
much time on email or on social media is
one of the top death bed regrets
have you thought about that um yeah it's
an interesting question because i don't
i don't know if it's going to last 50
years this this type of behavior i i
think where
when you look at techno cycles there's
this initial roughly 10-year period
where
we have exuberance and experimentation
right so if something really interesting
new technology comes along
it opens up a lot of new opportunities
that didn't exist before
the first period is typically one of
experimentation exuberance right
this is where you tend to see a lot of
extreme behaviors what happens next in
the the tech adoption cycle
is that we get past that and begin to
settle in and make decisions about
all right all right we're used to this
now how do we actually want to integrate
it into our lives long term
and the hope is when you get to that
phase things become more reasonable i
think that's the transition we're making
now with smartphone use
we created this large attention economy
we have these very
uh appealing apps we were using them in
an experimental exuberant mindset those
two things came together and suddenly
we're looking at these things all the
time
especially for very young because the
the let's say like the adolescent brain
has a very hard time trying to deal with
socially engineered distraction right
these are unformed brains that
that hyper focus on sociality so it's
really really
uh really really appealing to them and
so we're using these things all the time
my observation working on digital
minimalism is that as of about 2017 most
people realized ah this is not great
okay uh let's we're going to need to
bring this back in
some as we move forward on the new
technologies and so i'm hoping
that the role that like our phone and
social media etc is going to play in our
lives it's going to it's going to rain
back in
over the next 10 years or so so
hopefully 50 years from now it'll be
more like looking back at that period
with a little bit of interest or maybe
even
tinged with a bit of embarrassment man
that 2010 to 2020 was a crazy time right
it was like the roaring 20s you know we
were all flapper dancing and speakeasies
um but we moved on and i think that's
gonna be the case i mean i'm not even a
big
believer in the idea that these having a
small number of giant social media
companies that
basically dominates interaction
expression on the internet the idea that
that's going to be long-term i don't
even think that's the case
i think even that we're going to look
back and be like that was this weird
period
where there's four or five companies
that just dominated people's interaction
expression on the internet
i don't think that's going to be a
long-term thing either i think that's
also going to be of the moment
and once you no longer have these giant
companies with their own private
versions of the internet they're trying
to monetize attention
a lot of the the excessive use is going
to go down and so i'm much more of an
optimist about where we're going to get
that's an oddly positive outlet i
thought
that you would have had something far
more apocalyptic to have been
cassandra about for the future what is
next
what can what can you talk about or what
you're working on next or what we can
expect from you over the next
couple of years you know i'm not sure
yet i'm thinking about it so
if you have a good idea i'm happy to
hear it i mean i'm a little farther
along than that
typically i do have a new book by the
time i publish one because
it's in the lead up once i'm done with
the book but it's not out yet
i need something for my mind to do so
that's typically when i start working on
the next book
this year i did a podcast instead
because of the pandemic and i was
feeling isolated from my reader so
i think starting up my podcast last may
took that part of my attention that
would have been we got to get moving on
the next book and so it slowed that down
a little bit so
i have a couple ideas i'm close to being
able to
to talk about them yet but i don't want
to talk about them until i've locked
them in because i'm not quite sure if
that's where i'm going to go
um but i i'm not it won't be long until
i'm back to writing again let's put it
that way
good i'll keep on pestering lillian and
she'll tell me i'll just keep on asking
for the
for the stories behind the scenes kyle
it's been awesome man it's been a very
long time to bring you on the show and
i'm glad that you
you finally made it a world without
email will be linked in the show notes
below
you're also a digital ghost so asking
where people can get you online is
kind of kind of a little bit difficult
what's your website
cal newport.com that's my my email
newsletter i write this weekly essay
uh i have a podcast of questions but
otherwise i'm very hard to find
and uh yeah it's by design everything
will be linked in the show notes below
cal thanks for today
well thank you thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that
then press here for a selection of the
best clips
from the podcast over the last few
months and don't forget to subscribe
it makes me very happy indeed peace